[Musique]
avez-vous eu une journée difficile agent fureur Je
vais avoir besoin d'éclaircissements sur cette invasion spatiale les
étendues infiltrent votre
planète ce sont des métamorphes
et je vais le faire Je suis sur le point de vous croire sur
parole aujourd'hui,
nous sommes très forts dans la caisse United
Control
J'ai ce pouvoir
mais je ne sais pas d'où il vient Je n'ai
jamais rien vu de tel que vous pensez
pouvoir trouver  nous, elle n'est que le début,
vous avez parcouru un long chemin, pas aussi fort que
vous le pensez,
qu'est-ce que ce logo de sceau fait annoncer
votre identité sur les vêtements aider avec la
partie secrète de votre travail a dit que le
soldat de l'espace portait un costume en caoutchouc
nous avons besoin de héros nous  besoin de toi Captain
Marvel parle de quelqu'un qui part en
voyage de découverte et je pense qu'il était
vraiment important pour le cerveau d'apprendre
à se battre au moment où nous avons commencé à tourner,
je m'entraînais depuis neuf mois et
je suis content de l'avoir
fait  mes séquences de haut en bas ou d'
entraînement  g pendant trois jours
bien vivant, la chose que j'ai
trouvée si unique à propos de ce personnage était
ce sens de l'humour mélangé à une
capacité totale et quel que soit le défi qui se présentait à
elle, vous n'êtes pas une chose noire, vous voyez,
ce que j'ai réalisé après être allé à Air
Force  La base est vraiment ce que
sont les pilotes de l'Air Force c'est une question oui ou non
oui
et nous avons simulé un combat aérien nous étions en
attaque nous étions sur la défense nous sommes arrivés à
6,5 G c'est incroyable c'est beaucoup beaucoup de travail
elle en apporte tellement à  le rôle
c'est assez génial
[Musique]
toi